[Music]
okay this is Bobo's acceptance speech I
first have to say there has been an
agonizing seven months at lease of
having the name Steve from Florida the
fans for the most part have been split
but many have been brutal to me on so
many levels
such as stealing my personal photos on
my Twitter and Facebook account and
putting them in horrible situations back
in early December of this year I had the
bobo name taken away from me by the
stern shell court due to pull a jew ism
because of me stealing a joke from
foxnews greg gutfeld during the
presidential election roughly thirty
years ago i came up with the name bobo
since then howard has developed me into
this peripheral character that quite
frankly has resonated with the fans all
over the country today is a milestone
where I have the opportunity to win back
my name provided I do the walk of shame
and my underwear through the streets of
Manhattan I also want to let it be known
that I have every intention of keeping
my name without having it being stripped
for me due to palatial ism or anything
else that may perhaps cross the line
with the show I will be very very
careful not to jeopardize this at all
course in closing I have so many great
memories over the years gone by with the
show that Bobo has been a part of and
for that I will be able grateful to you
Howard thanks for letting me be part of
the greatest show on earth
Bobo out